salut à tous les pêcheurs de trésors
alors aujourd'hui je suis à béziers bon
du masque obligatoire
donc c'est un point où je suis déjà
venue et j'ai sorti le pistolet le
français et ça fait six mois je suis pas
venu
[Musique]
je fais vraiment le bord parce que c'est
là qu'il ya le plus de choses avec ce
que les gens vont tomber des péniches
nos les mains des conneries au bord
[Musique]
somda
ah c'est pas mal morceaux de cadix
cuivre étaient attachés sait pas trop
comment
l'un d'eux
ah ouais tu sais le faire qui s'est mis
dedans
boules de pétanque
pas mal
récolte
un essuie glace
petit hic la caisse c'est les francs
2000 francs france ouai demi francs 2000
ces dernières années sa dédicace cette
pièce à notre abonnés dima youtube qui
nous suit depuis longtemps
merci anonyme à un coach à ça ça va être
un morceau de poteaux électriques aussi
avec les fils qui vont autour de falla
un vieux poteaux électriques
sympa
aux âmes ans passés un couteau
un opinel
my way vieux cela et j'ai peut-être
récupérables sympa l'opinel nickel ça je
regardais j'ai essayé de nettoyer la
provence bien aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça
forte de pitié c'est paulo
vous avez une idée dites le moi dans les
commentaires
c'est quoi ça ça aussi je sais pas du
tout ce qui restait des gars
[Musique]
bizarre
il ya des choses bizarres dans ce canal
moi je vous le dit
la casserole
et c'est quoi ça
stop et un burin ou sais pas
c'est par django est maintenant c'est
pas pointu coran vieil objet étrange et
qui fait le chien aller
[Musique]
correct
juste au large
voir ces corps
[Rires]
m
les radiateurs
un vieux radiateurs à hélette
si je dis pas de conneries françois de
sales dû faire au mieux mais ça n'ont
pas dû faire ça
alors que le bord oui
un pas
sympa le petit radiateur on leur fait
plus depuis belle lurette des comme ça
les quelques cents après les radiateurs
ça va être une autre partie ou quoi je
suis cause
leur départ tenir tout
impôts
quoi c'est un pot d'échappement ouais
un vrai convaincre le canal pour une
déchetterie ici alloresto d'en face qui
met la table ça me donnait pas allé
comme parade la pièce belle fourchette à
salah elle est bien l irréparable
je regarde nickel
allez on continue pas quelque chose de
gros encore un gros
ouais quand même quelques kilos
warsh ça
passez plus donc ça mais ça c'est encore
un morceau de moteur
donc là je vais me sortir pièces de
centimes
[Musique]
peuple de 2008
ça paye le trajet est ensuite avant j'ai
fait un antivol bien vieux et bien pour
afin que ce n'est même pas été cassées
et une super fils aussi ça c'est de la
pollution en moins on va l'amener au
recyclage condor deviendront ainsi qu'un
briquet brûlé voilà donc on continue
oh what the fuck une chaise une chaise
de pêcheurs nice c'est bon ça
ça c'est bon elle est en parfaite état
nickel et ça c'est ce que je disais
celle-là elle n'était pas là avant que
je passais est arrivé cette année les
spots comme ça je pense qu'ils peuvent
être fait tous les ans peut-être à la
fin de l'été donc là je viens de
remonter deux barres de fer et surtout
regarder dédicace cette superbe
retrouver le chien de revolver à hugo
détection notre fidèle abonné je vais
tire exactement au même endroit pour
voir si je peux pas le choper en
longeant le borgne non encore de la
barre de péniches
une petite cuillère
un bouchon de réservoir par la boule de
pétanque seront à la 5ème que je fasse
ce spot deuxième aujourd'hui un truc de
fou j'ai sorti 10 piqué et là je vais me
faire leurs taux en plus et encore
regardez abbas est pas impliqué
au caire et du français
et l'art d'être là à mettre le chien
dans la poche aussi à une hausse à
l'état c'est normal ça parce qu'ils ont
mis dans l'eau ouais voilà la pêche
surtout sera touché à sa fin donc moi
j'ai gagné une chaise et d'un ferraille
donc en fait ça me va on se retrouve
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo il
s'avise appli n'hésitez pas à lâcher un
petit peu de bleu et à vous abonner à la
chaîne et moi je vous dis à bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo